Palestinian officials call
it madness
that could inflame the entire region.
But Israelis
who took part in a controversial march
say it's just the beginning
of retaking land
they believe belongs to them.
Thousands of settlers marched
to an evacuated outpost
in the occupied West Bank today.
As you can see,
they're under the heavy protection
of soldiers to far right.
Israeli ministers
and some parliament members
were among them
protesting their own government's policy
that considers the outpost illegal.
Palestinians
in a nearby village protested the march,
some clashing with Israeli forces.
The Palestinian red Crescent says 216
people were injured,
some by rubber bullets.
Elsewhere in the West
Bank, mourners buried a 15 year old
Palestinian boy
killed by Israeli soldiers
in a refugee camp near Jericho.
Israel says its forces came under attack
during a raid to arrest a tourist,
a terror suspect.
So they responded,
they say, with live fire.
I want to bring in our correspondent
Frederik Pleitgen
is following developments
tonight for us from Jerusalem. Fred.
Good to see you. This evening.
So we've heard, I believe,
from the Israeli prime minister, Benjamin
Netanyahu in the last,
what, 20 minutes or so. What did he say
Well,
you say he certainly didn't
sound like he was going to back down
or make any concessions.
In fact,
he opened his speech
that he gave tonight,
which you're absolutely right.
Ended just a couple of minutes ago
saying that Israel was,
as he put it, under a terror attack.
And then he outlined
some of the
what he called very tough measures
that the Israeli government
has taken in the past couple of days,
saying, for instance,
that they hit both Hezbollah
and Hamas targets
last week
and, of course, over the weekend as well.
Then having hit
Hezbollah targets is certainly something
new that the Israelis
so far hadn't said before.
What he also did is
he took a couple of jibes
at the predecessor government
and in fact, Naftali Bennett,
who headed that government,
he has already tweeted, calling
Netanyahu's speech disgraceful.
But you are also absolutely right.
You thought
that all of this comes
in an extremely charged atmosphere.
And, you know,
we were at that march
that took place today by those settlers.
And here's what we witnessed
amid an already
highly charged atmosphere.
Thousands of Israeli settlers
marched in the West Bank
to an abandoned settlement called Evitar
demanding to open it back up,
ready to fight for it.
If it need to be with our enemy.
And it will be our government,
because nobody
will disconnected from this land
Avatar is classified
as an illegal outpost
by Israel's government
built on land Palestinians say they own.
But now even members
of Benjamin Netanyahu's
cabinet are marching here
like the far right
national security minister
who we met with me,
Sir Hassan,
who is strong in
Avatar, will be strong in Tel Aviv.
He told us.
We won't give in to terror.
Not an Avatar, not in Tel Aviv.
The really large turnout here
at this demonstration
and the folks who came here,
they do feel that there is a government
in power in this country
now that's more
sympathetic to their demands
and they demand
that they be allowed
to have more settlements in this area.
Even though we have many, many Arab
settlements over here.
But this area is the land of the Bible.
Okay, we'll be here.
Abraham Isaac and Yaakov
went and walked in this area.
So we want
we're just a continuation of them.
But the violence continues to spiral.
The current crisis started when Israeli
security forces
raided the Al-Aqsa Mosque
in Jerusalem twice
last week, arresting hundreds of people
Israel answered a barrage of rockets
fired from Lebanon in Gaza
with airstrikes.
And even this weekend, things
didn't stop.
Israeli warplanes and drones
bombed positions in Syria
after several rockets were fired
from there
towards the Israeli
occupied Golan Heights
along long
And Monday,
the Israeli military shot
and killed a 15 year old boy,
Mohammed Fayez Bohan,
in another part of the West Bank.
The Palestinian Ministry of Health says
They shot him in the
head during the raid.
What will happen to us?
What is going to happen
to our Palestinian people?
The Israelis say
their forces were attacked
during an anti-terror
raid in the village back
near the abandoned settlement.
Palestinians who say they own
this land
confronted Israeli security forces
as the settlers were marching,
vowing to build even more outposts
with high members of Israel's government
backing their quest.
Despite the risk of further
inflaming a country
and a region already on the brink,
as you can see, it's
an extremely volatile
situation here on the ground.
And certainly
there is a lot of concern internationally
that all this could spiral
into an even worse place.
And if you look at those clashes
that took place today
near that march where we were.
The Palestinian authorities
are now saying
that more than 200 people
were injured in those clashes.
So obviously the violence continues
and there certainly
is the danger that that violence
could get worse. Isa?
Yeah,
and it's not just
the violence continuing.
Tragedy comes with it
because the mother,
of course,
of the two
British Israeli sisters were killed
in that shooting
in the West
Bank on Friday,
we believe has died of her injuries.
Just remind us, Fred,
of what happened here
Yes, certainly that was
one of those incidents on Friday.
Friday,
of course, was extremely violent day
here on the ground.
We had a ramming attack
that took place in the evening
in Tel Aviv.
But earlier in the West Bank,
there was a shooting incident
where a car received
a bullet shot or gunshots
with a family in it.
It was a mother
and her
two daughters
and the two daughters were killed
in that crash.
They were pronounced dead at the scene.
And the word
at that point in time
was that the mother had survived
but was in very grave condition.
Now, she has also succumbed to her
wounds.
Her funeral is set for tomorrow,
as you say.
And that,
of course,
is something
that is extremely emotional,
not just for the family,
but also for this entire country.
In fact, the eulogy,
the service
for the two daughters were something
that was broadcast here on national TV.
And certainly we expect the same thing
to happen tomorrow as well.
So certainly
another thing
that really
inflames tensions here on the ground
is, as we can see,
it certainly shows no signs of this
calming down anytime soon Isa.
Fred Pleitgen for us
this hour in Jerusalem.
Thanks very much, Fred.